ELON MUSK'S JET BEING TRACKED BY
A TEENAGER WHO, BY THEAY IS MY
NEXT GUEST, I IMMEDIATELY
THOUGHT OF A SCENE FROM THE
LEGENDARY MOVIE "WALL STREET."
DO YOU REMEMBER A YOUNG TRADER
IS PLAYED BY CHARLIE SHEEN AND
IN THIS SCENE, HE'S BEEN
ENLISTED TO SPY ON A BUSINESS
RIVAL.
>> EXCUSE ME, EXCUSE ME.
IS MR. -- ABOARD THAT PLANE --
[ BLEEP ] MY BOSS IS GOING TO
KILL ME.
DO YOU KNOW WHERE THAT PLANE IS
GOING?
>> ERIE, PENNSYLVANIA.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> 19-YEAR-OLD JACK SWEENEY HAS
BEEN TRACKING THE TESLA SPACEX
BILLIONAIRE'S GULF STREAM.
ON TWITTER, SAYS ELONJET USES
PUBLIC RECORDS TO TRACK THE
FLIGHTS BUT ALSO LIKE MOGULS
LIKE JEFF BEZOS.
BUT MUSK SENT HIM A PRIVATE
MESSAGE ASKING HIM TO STOP.
MUSK'S DIRECT MESSAGE WHICH
SWEENEY SHARED WITH US BUT WE'VE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO VERIFY BY
SPACEX IS THIS.
YOU CAN TAKE THIS DOWN, IT'S A
SECURITY RISK?
SWEENEY APPLIED, YES, I CAN, IT
WILL COST YOU A MODEL 3 ONLY
JOKING UNLESS -- QUESTION MARK.
>> MUSK OFFERED HIM $5,000
WRITING I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
BEING SHUT DOWN BY A NUT CASE.
SWEENEY COUNTERED ASKING FOR
50,000.
>> MUSK SAID IT DIDN'T FEEL
LIKE, QUOTE, PAY TO SHUT THIS
DOWN.
SWEENEY REPLIED OPTIONS LIKE
REMUNERATION LIKE AN INTERNSHIP
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER.
IT HAS 375,000 FOLLOWERS.
RECENTLY, THE CEO OF A CAR
LEASING COMPANY OFFERED JACK A
THREE-YEAR LEASE ON TO TAKE THE
ACCOUNT DOWN.
HE'S HOLDING FIRM.
WE REACHED OUT TO MUSK, HE'S
APPARENTLY NOT AVAILABLE.
JACK SWEENEY JOINS ME FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CENTRAL FLORIDA.
JACK, WHAT ARE YOU MAJORING IN
AND WHAT IS YOUR CAREER
ASPIRATION?
>> MAJORING HERE IN I.T. IN UCF.
AND I WANT TO DO SOFTWARE
AVIATION LIKE I AM RIGHT NOW,
BASICALLY.
>> WHAT WAS THE PLAN WHEN YOU
STARTED TRACKING ELON MUSK'S
GULFSTREAM?
>> I WAS A MAN OF ELON AND TESLA
AND SPACEX AND EVERYTHING HE'S
GOT GOING ON.
JUST INTERESTED IN WHERE HE'S
GOING.
JUST A HOBBY TO SEE WHAT
BUSINESS HE WAS UP.
>> FAIR TO SAY, THOUGH, THAT
NEVER WAS THE GOAL, HEY, I'M
GOING TO TRACK HIM AND GET HIM
TO PAY ME MONEY?
>> NO, I WAS A FAN.
I'D NEVER WANT TO JUST TRY TO
GET MONEY OUT OF HIM.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE CONCERN THAT
HE RAISES THAT PERHAPS THIS
POSES A SECURITY THREAT?
>> YOU KNOW, THERE IS SOME MERIT
TO THAT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW IF
HE'S BEING COMPLETELY TRUTHFUL
THAT IT'S ALL SECURITY.
MAYBE HE JUST DOESN'T WANT TO BE
SEEN.
AND I DON'T THINK THE SECURITY
RISK -- IT'S THAT BIG BECAUSE
EVEN JUST RECENTLY, ELON HAD AN
EVENT IN TEXAS.
SOMEONE ASKED HIM IF HE WOULD
COME TO THIS PUBLIC EVENT, AND
HE SAID, SURE.
IF HE CAN GO TO EVENTS LIKE
THAT, I DON'T THINK HE HAS THAT
BIG OF A SECURITY RISK.
>> LISTEN, "WALL STREET," THE
MOVIE IS BEFORE YOUR TIME.
IT'S A HELL OF A FILM AND
IMPACTED MY GENERATION.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE ABLE TO
SEE THE CLIP THAT WE PLAYED.
HERE'S A POINT I WAS MAKING
THERE'S PROBABLY A GREAT DEAL TO
BE LEARNED ABOUT MUSK
BUSINESSWISE BY KNOWING HIS
PHYSICAL WHEREABOUTS?
HAS THAT OCCURRED TO YOU?
>> YEAH, IT HAS.
AFTER I STARTED, YOU SEE WHERE
HE'S GOING THAT YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
BEFORE, ALL THE TESLA FACTORIES,
ALL THE SPACEX PLACES, HE'S
GOING TO THOSE.
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> HAS HE MADE IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR YOU TO TRACK HIS FLIGHTS?
>> YES.
HE GOT MOST -- THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF BLOCKING.
BUT ACTUALLY, JUST IN THE PAST
COUPLE DAYS IT'S BEEN TURNED
OFF.
I MEAN, HAVE THEY GIVEN UP?
I GUESS.
IT'S REALLY STRANGE.
>> IS THIS BASED ON ALL PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION?
IF I HAD YOUR LEVEL OF KNOWLEDGE
AND SOPHISTICATION, WOULD I BE
ABLE TO DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
DOING?
>> YEAH, YOU'D BE ABLE TO TRACK
THIS FLIGHT LIKE I AM ON
TWITTER.
>> WHO ELSE ARE YOU TRACKING AND
WHY?
>> WE HAVE BEEN BILL GATES, JEFF
BEZOS.
TRUMP.
MARK ZUCKERBERG.
MARK CUBAN.
AND, YOU KNOW, JUST PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED.
AFTER I STARTED THE FIRST ONE,
PEOPLE WERE ASKING FOR OTHERS.
I STARTED THAT AND ADDING THEM.
>> HAS ANYBODY ELSE BEEFED THE
WAY THAT MUSK HAS?
>> NO.
I MEAN, THE ACCOUNTS AREN'T AS
BIG.
MUSK IS REALLY BIG ON TWITTER SO
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S
GOTTEN AS BIG AS IT HAS.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S AS MUCH
ATTENTION ON OTHER ONES LIKE
E
ELON'S.
>> WHAT IS YOUR CURRENT DEMAND,
RELATIVE TO MUSK, WHAT WOULD IT
TAKE TO GO AWAY AND STOP THIS?
>> STILL A TESLA AND $50,000.
I'M NOT GOING TO UP IT.
THERE'S NO NEED TO.
>> I BET PEOPLE WHO ARE WATCHING
THIS ARE MAKING A DETERMINATION
WHETHER THIS IS AMBITION, THIS
IS IN THE AMERICAN SPIRIT OR
WHENEVER IT GETS A BIT
OBNOXIOUS, YOU WOULD TELL THEM
WHAT?
>> I JUST STARTED AS A HOBBY.
I DON'T WANT TO LET GO OF A
HOBBY FOR SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
REALLY GOING TO CHANGE MY LIFE,
YOU KNOW.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I ENJOY
DOING AND I FIND IT REALLY COOL
TO DO.
>> BUT THE NEW TESLA, THAT WOULD
CHANGE YOUR LIFE?
>> YEAH, I DON'T HAVE A CAR
RIGHT NOW.
AND IT WOULD BE GREAT TO HAVE A
CAR AND IT WOULD BE A REALLY
COOL CAR.
>> I'M SURE THAT HE PROBABLY --
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M A MUSK FAN MYSELF.
I'M SURE THAT HE ADMIRED THIS IN
PART BUT THINKS IF HE SETTLED UP
WITH YOU THE WAY YOU WANT, HE'S
OPENING UP A DOOR --
>> YES, OTHER PEOPLE WOULD WANT
TO DO IT, TOO.
>> YEAH, I HEAR YOU.
WELL, I WISH YOU GOOD THINGS
WITH YOUR STUDIES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
VIA MY SMERCONISH TWITTER AND
FACEBOOK PAGES FROM THE WORLD OF
TWITTER.
LAUGH OUT LOUD, I HAVE OWNED A
TESLA FOR SIX YEARS AND YOU ARE
A RELATIVELY NEW OTHER THAN OOP
LONE MUSK HAS BEEN TRACKING OUR
PRIVATE CARS AND DRIVING SKILL
SETS FOR YEARS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL NOW?
THAT IS SO FUNNY.
QUICK STORY.
IN OUR HOUSE, WE WERE PLAYING
OCULUS THIS WEEK WHICH IS OWNED,
I THINK, BY FACEBOOK.
ONE OF MY SONS SAID, DAD,
IMAGINE IF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
SAID WE WANT TO PUT A CAMERA IN
YOUR LIVING ROOM.
WE'D BE LIKE, DON'T TREAD ON ME,
OVER MY DEAD BODY.
AND YE